et plus tard à l'émission des auteurs
d'attentats
d'attac chimiques et même d'assassinât
qui sont démasqués par de simples
citoyens qui décortique des vidéos sur
le web les citoyens qui téléchargent ces
contenus veulent que le monde entier
sache que ce qu'ils vivent est bien
réelle que ce n'est pas faux les snacks
fait
on vous amène ce soir à la rencontre
d'un groupe d'enquêteurs dont certains
sont de simples citoyens qui dissèque le
web pour démasquer des auteurs de crimes
graves
pensez aux attaques chimiques en syrie
au meurtre de dissidents russes et même
à cet avion de la malaysia airlines qui
a été abattu en ukraine et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils utilisent
facebook twitter youtube et ce groupe
qui s'appelle berline cap fait des
révélations fracassantes
[Applaudissements]
l'attaquant gaz toxique a fait au moins
65 morts et 350 blessés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lieu de la taxe serait khan cheikhoun
en série un village aux mains du front
elle ne sera la branche syrienne d'al
qaïda les images sont effectivement
choquantes difficile à regarder
comme ils n'ont pas de journalistes sur
le terrain des médias occidentaux relais
ces vidéos mises en ligne par des
témoins qui disent être sur place
les armes chimiques aurait été larguée
par des avions chasseurs de l'armée de
bachar al assad
damas réagi rapidement
comme souvent le président syrien est
catégorique
bachar al assad a dit comment peut-on
vérifier des vidéos ce qui est
complètement risible
selon nous parce qu'un simple citoyen pu
authentifier une vidéo
en quelques étapes faciles février
[Musique]
quelques heures après la taxe chimique a
dit al khatib s'est tout de suite mis au
travail à partir de son bureau de berlin
so what we day 2 une des premières
vidéos que nous avons trouvée était
celle ci elle a été publié par un
utilisateur du nom de mohamed salem à la
boudent le 4 avril 2017
on devine on entend qu'il mentionne la
date 4 avril 2017 et le lieu khan
cheikhoune dans son enquête a dit ne
tient rien pour acquis
il vérifie chaque détail la première
chose que nous voulions vérifier et
l'heure à laquelle cette vidéo a été
mise en ligne sur youtube ce qui nous
aide ensuite à comprendre quand cette
frappe aérienne a eu lieu
il consulte une base de données
d'amnesty international qui recense
l'heure où tous les vidéos sont mises en
ligne sur you to mais nous avons pu
établir que cette vidéo a été
téléchargée sur youtube
à 8 heures du matin heure de damas ce
qui signifie que l' attaque a eu lieu
plus tôt ou tard à peine byford attaque
mais d'autres sources contredisent
l'affirmation de bachar al assad
quant à l'heure de la tacc à 6h24 heure
locale un médecin annonce dans son
compte twitter que des victimes
commencent à arriver à son hôpital laval
hop au feq vidéo venant utilisé des
images choquantes hors contexte est une
tactique de guerre répandu en effet
quelles sont les preuves que l'attaqué a
eu lieu à khan cheikhoune une étudiante
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pouvoir
déterminer où a été filmé cette vidéo
pour pouvoir être certain qu'elle est
authentique et n'est pas une tentative
de désinformation en utilisant des
banques d'imagés satellites comme google
earth a dit arrive à repérer des
éléments qui apparaissent dans la vidéo
par exemple cette colline au centre de
l'image est le cas les hausses et les
minarets des mosquées
ensemble ces éléments lui permet de
confirmer que la vidéo a bel et bien été
filmé à khan cheikhoune
il arrive même à déduire l'endroit exact
où se trouvait la personne qui a filmé
la tacc nous sommes assurés de vérifier
chaque information publiée en ligne
relativement à cet incident dans le
cadre de notre enquête et nous avons
publié nos résultats restent guen a noué
un peuple d'achat dès le lendemain de
l'attaqué le groupe des dix publient les
premiers résultats de son enquête sur
son blog heures lieu et types de
munitions sont identifiés les autres le
résultat auquel nous arrivons et que la
cause la plus probable de cette attaque
chimique est une frappe aérienne par
l'aviation de l'armée syrienne a dit
travaille à berlin
il fait partie d'une organisation
appelée belle incat pourquoi est ce si
important d'enquêter maintenant est de
recueillir ces informations à partir de
l'extérieur de la syrie
c'est très important parce que c'est
parfois la seule preuve que nous avons
des violations des droits de la personne
en syrie
les méthodes banque est utilisé par bell
incat permettent de désamorcer
rapidement les tentatives de
désinformation
délicate a été fondée en 2014 par un
britannique
même s'il n'est pas du tout un
spécialiste elia trigun a démontré qu'il
est relativement facile de décortiquer
l'information accessible sur internet
prenait 4 et groupe bel incat est un
groupe de chercheurs et de journalistes
certains ont une expertise technique et
il utilise l'information en ligne
disponible à tous les internautes
il enquête donc simplement en fouillant
sur internet pour trouver des documents
des vidéos et photos des bases de
données qui permettent de documenter des
violations des droits de la personne des
cas de corruption ou d'autres problèmes
dans le monde
un adage les choses à l'endroit
elliott higgins a commencé seul dans son
salon à faire des enquêtes sur des
crimes de guerre commis en syrie à
partir du web délicate ce sont
maintenant très enquêteurs dispersés
dans plusieurs pays
à berlin a dit m khatib est responsable
d'amasser des preuves sur le conflit
syrien week-end jusqu'à présent nous
repérons chaque jour environ 500 vidéo
uniquement sur youtube
mais si on ajoute à ça les messages
facebook twitter et d'autres plateformes
il y en a des milliers quotidiennement
hadi a amassé jusqu'ici près de 800
mails vidéos sur le conflit syrien et
les archives dans l'immense base de
données publique qu'il a créé sur yonne
ak les vidéos sont ainsi préservés et
les informations qui s'y rattachent
aussi pour l'avocat américain reed brody
qui a poursuivi plusieurs criminels de
guerre les vidéos sont un maillon
essentiel dans une preuve et a beaucoup
de différents types de preuves
il ya aussi des preuves qui sont ou des
éléments qui servent à dramatiser et
attirer l'attention
donc les vidéos parlent plus sain
évidemment que un document qui gardait
dans un dans un bâtiment un vidéo à
valeur évident évident de preuves en
même temps sapin vidéo ça peut être
manipulé ça peut être on ne sait pas
l'histoire qui est derrière
d'où l'importance du travail de belles
incat à authentifier les vidéos
ce que nous essayons de faire est de
tout centraliser dans un seul endroit et
ensuite d'en vérifier l'authenticité et
nous avons adopté une méthodologie
claire pour le faire sans cet outil les
enquêteurs les avocats et les procureurs
qui auront à travailler dans l'avenir
devrait partir de zéro
la russie le grand allié de la syrie
déploie un arsenal de communication pour
semer le doute sur ce qui s'est passé à
khan cheikhoune belle incat retrouve sur
youtube une conférence de presse des
autorités russes sur ce vote se doit
vidéo ceci at il dit à g à l'appui des
militaires veulent démontrer que le
sahara n'a pas pu être largué à partir
d'une bombe
pour expliquer leur théorie il présente
pour la première fois le schéma d'une
bombe utilisée dans le conflit syrien
en voyant cette vidéo a dit faire lien
avec une photo du lieu de l'attaqué
photo chewing gum cette photo montre des
fragments de la bombe retrouvée sur
place par data news
cette photo montre une pièce de métal
qui pourrait correspondre à un bouchon
servant à fermer la bombe qui contenait
le liquide toxique le sarin dans ce cas
nous savons que c'est soit l'armée de
l'air russe qui a utilisé cette bôme ce
jour là soit le gouvernement syrien qui
utilisent habituellement aussi des
munitions russe ironiquement ce sont les
autorités russes qui ont fourni la pièce
de castets qui manquait
[Musique]
plusieurs mois après le bombardement de
khan cheikhoun l'onu a confirmé que
bénigne cats avaient eu raison sur
plusieurs points elle a même repris
plusieurs de ses éléments dans ses
rapports d'enquêté après la pause les
enquêteurs de belinga devons découvrir
qui a battu la viande la malaysia
airlines qui a fait près de 300 morts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui a fait connaître
internationalement berline 4 c'est son
enquête sur l'écrasement du vol m h 17
de la malaysia airlines en juillet 2014
l'avion parti d'amsterdam est disparu
soudainement au dessus de l'ukraine une
zone où on soupçonnait les forces russes
d'être secrètement déployés l'enquète du
bureau de la sécurité aérienne des
pays-bas a déterminé que c'était un
missile sol air qui a battu l'avion
béline cat est allé plus loin
ils ont réussi à identifier l'unité
militaire russe à l'origine du tir qui a
fait 298 victimes
moscou ni toujours sa responsabilité
blink a également fourni des éléments à
l' enquête sur l'assassinât du
journaliste pavel charest mette en
juillet dernier à kiev
[Musique]
un membre de l'équipe à décortiquer une
vidéo de surveillance image par image
pour en faire 500 photos
en les superposant une sur l'autre il a
réussi à obtenir une photo très claire
de la plaque d'immatriculation d'une des
voitures qui pourrait être lié à
l'attentât
cette découverte a permis à des
journalistes d'établir que c'est en fait
un agent des services secrets ukrainiens
qui étaient dans la voiture ce soir-là
avec le même procédé vélines kate a pu
identifier le numéro de plaque d'un
véhicule diplomatique stationné devant
le consulat d'arabie saoudite en turquie
au moment où le journaliste jamal
khashoggi a été assassiné dans une autre
enquête b l'inkatha trouver la véritable
identité de deux individus soupçonnés
d'avoir empoisonné l'ex espion sergueï
skripal et sa fille en angleterre
belenkaïa a passé en revue des bases de
données russe analyser des photos d'une
académie militaire
pour conclure que l'identité des deux
suspects retenue par la police
londonienne étaient en fait des
pseudonymes
il s'agirait de deux agents de la grc
les services secrets russes but
l'inkatha et si contredit la version
officielle russe selon laquelle les deux
individus n'étaient que des touristes
de son côté le syrien a dit al khatib
est réfugié en allemagne depuis le début
du conflit en série il espère que les
preuves qu'ils amassent servent dans un
éventuel procès contre le régime syrien
céline people
les syriens qu'ils soient de simples
citoyens ou des journalistes qui
téléchargent ces contenus veulent
s'assurer que d'autres soient témoins de
ce qui se passe dans leur pays qu'ils
soient informés des violations des
droits humains et ils veulent que le
monde entier sache que ce qu'ils vivent
est bien réel et que ce n'est pas faux
contrairement à ce qu'affirme le
gouvernement syrien
[Musique]
on espère que vous avez apprécié les
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été lent
et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]